[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne gellineck guten Abend die
Europäische Union nimmt
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der
kriegsgebeutelten Ukraine auf so der
einstimmige Beschluss der EU
Mitgliedstaaten also einstimmig -1 denn
einer der die ganze Zeit dagegen gewütet
hatte der ungarische Premierminister
Vikor Orban verließ während der
Abstimmung in Brüssel einfach den Raum
drin blieben 26 Staats- und
Regierungschefs und Chefinnen die dann
einstimmig dafür votierten Viktor Orban
der dienstälteste in der Gipfelrunde
hatte sowohl für die Beitrittsgespräche
als auch für die ukrainehilfen ein Veto
angekündigt
der streitlustige Ungar ist ein Champion
im EU gipfelpoker aber auch im
plötzlichen Einlenken Gunar Krüger
berichtet aus
Brüssel eine Menschenmenge und
mittendrin ein Ratspräsident das ist das
Zeichen die EU hat
entschieden es ist ein historischer
Moment er zeigt die Glaubwürdigkeit und
die Stärke der Europäischen Union es
hätte auch anders kommen
können Viktor Orban muss warten bis ein
Platz vor den Mikros frei wird es ist
Vormittag und Ungarns premier droht noch
mit einem Veto in zwei Streitpunkten der
erste die Aufnahme von
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der
Ukraine dafür gibt es sieben
Vorbedingungen die EU-Kommission sagt
drei der sieben Vorbedingungen sind
nicht erfüllt wir brauchen also gar
nicht erst zu
reden offene Bedingungen für einen
EU-Beitritt der Ukraine gibt es bei der
Korruptionsbekämpfung dem Einfluss von
Oligarchen und dem Schutz nationaler
Minderheiten anders als Orban vertrauen
aber die anderen 26 darauf die Ukraine
werde hier noch nacharbeiten dazu kommt
noch ein Streitpunkt 50 Milliarden Euro
um die Ukraine vor dem Bankrott zu
retten wird Orban hier sein Veto
aufgeben ich bin nicht optimistisch
nein denn dieses Foto spricht bende
Orbans Minister mit Münzen und der
Botschaft lieber spät als nie die EU
hatte Ungarn wegen bängeln in der Justiz
31 Milliarden Euro gesperrt gab einen
Teil davon aber gestern frei ein
Deal Hary Ungarn verbindet seine
Probleme nicht mit denen der Ukraine das
ist nicht unser Stil Orban hört die
Fragen hört die Mahnungen von volodomir
selenski wie so oft kurz zugeschaltet
zum Gipfel diesmal stellt der Ukrainer
sein Rede ins Netz und warnt vor einem
Scheitern putin wird das natürlich gegen
sie persönlich nutzen gegen ganz
Europa schenken Sie ihm nicht seinen
ersten und einzigen Sieg in diesem
Jahr dazu kommt es nicht die
Beitrittsverhandlungen beginnen wir
haben viel Arbeit in den Gipfel gesteckt
wichtig war dass kein Mitgliedstaat
gegen die Entscheidung Stimmen W
doch Oran kartet nach per Video hält die
Entscheidung weiter für komplett sinnlos
und unvernünftig den Sitzungsraum hatte
er offenbar bewusst
verlassen wenn du zustimmst dann musst
du danach auch deinen Mund
halten das hätte ich nicht sagen sollen
schließlich geht der Gipfel noch immer
weiter landete am Nachmittag
überraschend zu einem Blitzbesuch beim
us-mitär in Wiesbaden beim EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel ist der bislang nicht
aufgetaucht seine emotionale
videoansprache aber hat wohl den ein
oder anderen Regierungschef beeindruckt
jetzt also die Entscheidung der EU
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
aufzunehmen fragen wir nach bei Ulf
Röller in Brüssel wie kam es am Ende zum
Einlenken von Viktor
orbanulf also ich glaube am da war
einfach der Druck zu groß dieser Druck
baute sich das ganze Tag über auf und
Viktor Orban musste eben aufpassen dass
er nicht irgendwann die Schraube
überzieht und dieser Gipfel komplett
scheitert nur an ihm es fing eben an mit
dieser Rede von selenski die sehr
emotional war und die mehr oder weniger
gesagt hat er braucht jetzt dieses
Signal aus Europa dass man die
Beitrittsgespräche beginnt das sei ganz
wichtig für sein Land als Motivation das
hat die Regierungschefs hier sehr sehr
beeindruckt viele haben sich darauf
gezogen und dann haben alle 26
nacheinander gesagt das muss jetzt
kommen und dann war Orban allein zu Haus
und dann kam der Ratspräsident Michelle
und der Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz auf
die Idee dass man ja eigentlich diesen
Trick anwenden könnte und schlug Orban
vor dass er mal kurz rausgeht und sie
währenddessen wenn er draußen ist
abstimmt damit war er zufrieden und hat
gesagt das macht er nun hat er das
Gesicht quasi gewahrt er hat nicht
zugestimmt er schimpft ja auch schon auf
den sozialen Medien und das noch
Wichtige ist dass ja nur die Gespräche
beschlossen worden sind also eine sehr
symbolische Handlung aber noch nicht
natürlich der Beitritt und bis dahin
muss der EU-Rat noch oft drüber
abstimmen und dann kann ja Orban auch
noch mal Wein sagen und genau das ist
jetzt erstmal Symbolik aber beim zweiten
gipfelthema geht's weniger um Symbolik
als knallhart ums Geld nämlich um den
EU-Haushalt und die Unterstützung der
Ukraine wird Orban auch hier Einlenken
nach ihrer Einschätzung also ist schwer
zu sagen weil da geht es wirklich um
ganz wichtige 50 Milliarden für die
Ukraine also aus der Delegation von
Orban hörte man dass er da durchaus
bereit ist mehr einzulenken aber da ist
auch eine ganz klare Strategie sollte
Orban nicht einlenken dann haben die 26
schon mehr oder weniger angedeutet dann
ziehen Sie das ohne ihn durch den
Haushalt Orban gibt sowieso nicht so
viel Geld für die Ukraine und dann kann
es sein dass man hier ohne Orban diese
Entscheidung trifft und dann werden
dieser Gipfel durch uns ein Erfolg weil
es in zwei Punkten der Ukraine helfen
würde
Ulf Röller war das unser Korrespondent
in Brüssel vielen Dank
dorthin interessant ist dass Vikor Orban
sich neuerdings sehr viel Sorgen um die
Korruption in der Ukraine macht dabei
regiert er ein Land in dem so viel
EU-Gelder versickern wie in keinem
anderen und zwar so heißt es in den
Taschen von Freunden und Verwandten von
Viktor Orban trotzdem bleibt es
natürlich richtig dass die Europäische
Union die Bekämpfung von Bestechung und
Machtmissbrauch zur Bedingung für die
Aufnahme von Beitrittsverhandlungen
macht so auch im Fall der Ukraine Tim
Kröger über den mühsamen Kampf gegen
Korruption in Kiev
rohe Beamte Minister und Parlamentarier
saßen schon in diesem Saal des höchsten
antikorruptionsgerichts sagt richichter
makian halabala mehr als 150 Urteile
wurden seit der Gründung 2019 gefällt
Hala selbst ist derzeit an rund 30
Verfahren beteiligt es sei ein zer Kampf
gegen die Korruption in der Ukraine
große Aktenberge und zu wenig Richter
verzögern die Prozesse sagt
er leider haben wir auch das Problem
dass die Anwälte der Angeklagten ihre
Verfahrensrechte
missbrauchen das verlängert die
Urteilsfindung immerhin selbst die
mächtigsten des Landes können hier vor
Gericht gestellt
werden ich denke wir auf dem Weg sind
Korruption erfolgreich zu bekämpfen aber
es ist ein langer Weg da sollten wir
ehrlich sein noch ist die Korruption
allgegenwerärtig regelmäßig kommen
spektakuläre Fälle ans Licht im Sommer
wurde der Gerichtspräsident des Obersten
Gerichtshofes knnasev wegen mutmaßlicher
Bestechung festgenommen der frühere
Verteidigungsminister Alexi resnikow
musste wegen Korruptionsvorwürfen gegen
sein Ministerium zurücktreten die
Europäische Union attestiert der Ukraine
dennoch Fortschritte bei der
Korruptionsbekämpfung unter anderem
wurde gerade ein Gesetz zur Aufstockung
des Personals der ukrainischen
Antikorruptionsbehörde von 700 auf 1000
umgesetzt ich glaube wirklich dass die
Ukraine genug getan hat um die EU
Beitrittsgespräche aufzunehmen es geht
ja noch nicht um den EU-Beitritt selbst
um das zu erreichen müssen wir noch viel
mehr tun die Aktivistin Daria kalenuk
kämpft seit Jahren gegen die Korruption
im Land ihr
antikorruptionszentrum versucht über
einen eigenen YouTube-Kanal aufzuklären
der Druck für die Bekämpfung der
Korruption komme vor allem auch aus der
Bevölkerung für die das Thema durch den
Krieg noch einmal wichtiger geworden sei
sagt
sie seit Beginn des russischen
angriffskriegs verstehen immer mehr
Menschen dass Korruption töten kann und
dass sie die staatlichen Institutionen
schwächt der Kampf gegen die Korruption
sei Teil des Kampfes gegen Russland das
auch durch Korruption versuche die
Ukraine zu zerstören sagt Daria
kalenju angeblich nutzt Vladimir Putin
ja keine westlichen Medien oder das
Internet aber heute Abend wird er
vielleicht doch eine Ausnahme machen zu
schön muss es für ihn sein aus dem
Kremmel zu zusehen wie schwer sich die
EU tut der Ukraine weitere Unterstützung
zu gewähren wie überhaupt der russische
Präsident in seiner
jahresendpressekonferenz einen sehr
zufriedenen Eindruck machte klar Kritik
am Krieg in der Ukraine Null unbequeme
Fragen perlten an ihm ab Armin Körper
hat sich das über vier Stunden lange
Spektakel
angesehen europäisches Zentrum heißt
diese Shoppingmall im Herzen von Moskau
und in der Tat hier lässt Europa grüßen
denn westliche waren des Einzelhandels
sind weitgehend nicht sanktioniert und
deshalb zahlreich vorhanden die
moskovita in Shoppinglaune und politisch
vor der Kamera zumindest ganz auf Kurs
manche sind in die Türkei oder nach
Paris gegangen weil es ihnen hier zu
schwierig war ich bleibe ich sehe hier
Möglichkeiten ich glaube dass sich
Russlands Wirtschaft entwickeln wird und
der Westen wird uns noch
hinterherlaufen da mag es wenig wundern
dass auch der erste Mann im stat bei
seiner Pressekonferenz und
Bürgersprechstunde vor Stolz nur so
strotzt Putin hat das
Verteidigungsbudget um 70% erhöht und
die Rüstung indrie hochgefahren damit
kann er ein Wirtschaftswachstum von
3inh%
verkünden die Standfestigkeit unseres
Wirtschafts und Finanzsystems kam wohl
für unsere sogenannten Partner im Westen
überraschend auch für viele von
uns per Skype erreichen wir den
Wirtschaftsfachmann wladislav inersemzev
der sich in Washington aufhält er
erklärt dass das Wachstum zwar auf Pump
ist der Westen aber unterschätzt hat d
Russland noch immer an Geld
kommt natürlich kann die russische
Regierung nicht für immer Geld leihen
und sie wird ihre Militärausgaben kaum
auf dem jetzigen Niveau für 5 oder 10
Jahre halten können aber am Ende steht
die Frage wer den längeren Atem hat die
Ukraine und der Westen oder
Russland Putin glaubt dass er den hat
aus dem ganzen Land werden ausgewählte
Bürger altet viele fragen wann der Krieg
vorbei ist wenn die Ziele erreicht sind
sagt der
Präsident alles was die Ukraine hat
kommt doch von außen und das kann Enden
tatsächlich sehen wir ja dass es schon
immer weniger
wird es mag Zufall sein dass heute der
usjournalist Evan görkovt vor Gericht
steht in Untersuchungshaft seit 260
Tagen wegen
spionagevorwurfs doch Zufälle sind
selten in der Putin Show und so spricht
der Präsident erstmals von einem
möglichen
Austausch wir sind im Kontakt mit den
amerikanischen Partnern wir verstehen
uns und die Sprache der
Gegenseite und dann will Putin noch
lustig sein ein mit künstlicher
Intelligenz erzeugtes Dubel wird
zugeschaltet um die doppelgängerfage ein
für alleal zu klären es kann nur einen
geben das war die Botschaft heute vom
Kriegsherrn in
der sich auf der siegesgraden
sieht und in den Nachrichten mit gundola
Gause blicken wir zunächst auf den
anderen Kriegsschauplatz der die Welt
beschäftigt ja die Kämpfe im
Gazastreifen dauern an und sie würden
weitergehen bekräftigte Israels
Regierungschef Netanyahu heute bis die
Terrororganisation Hamas besiegt sei
weite Teile des Gazastreifens sind
mittlerweile zerstört bei immer neuen
israelischen Luftangriff auf Rafa wurden
mehr als 20 Menschen getötet das
israelische Militär veröffentlichte
außerdem diese Bilder mutmaßlicher
Extremisten in Berlin im
niederländischen Rotterdam und in
Dänemark sind insgesamt sieben
mutmaßliche hamasmitglieder festgenommen
worden wegen des Verdachts der
Vorbereitung von Anschlägen auf jüdische
Einrichtungen drei der Festnahmen
erfolgten in Berlin dort sollen die
Männer nach einem im Waffenversteck
gesucht haben die Bundesanwaltschaft
verdächtig die Festgenommenen der engen
Zusammenarbeit mit Hamas
führungsmitgliedern mit dem Schutz und
mit Perspektiven jüdischen Lebens in
Deutschland befasst sich in Berlin der
Gemeindetag des Zentralrats der Juden in
Deutschland Bundespräsident Steinmeier
sprach zum Auftakt Jüdinnen und Juden
weitere Solidarität aus und betonte
erneut Antisemitismus werden nicht
Geduld
und weiterhin bekämpft Deutschland wird
und dafür trete ich persönlich ein dafür
tritt die übergroße Mehrheit aller
deutschen ein eine Heimat für Juden
bleiben die Bundesregierung hat sich mit
der Türkei darauf verständigt die
Entsendung von Imamen aus der Türkei
schrittweise zu beenden stattdessen
sollen pro Jahr 100 Imame in Deutschland
ausgebildet werden und die rund 1000
hierzu zuande
tätigen Prediger der türkischen
Religionsbehörde nach und nach ersetzen
die türkischen Staatsbeamten Folgen
Weisungen aus Ankara und haben meist nur
geringe Kenntnisse der deutschen
Lebensrealität der bayerische AFD
Landtagsabgeordnete Daniel halemba gibt
mit sofortiger Wirkung alle Parteiämter
ab ihm droht ein
Parteiausschlussverfahren dabei geht es
um den Vorwurf hember habe daran
mitgewirkt Mitglieder nicht
satzungskonform in die AFD aufzunehmen
damit sie bei der Aufstellung zur
Landtagswahl für ihn stimmten wegen des
Verdachts der Volksverhetzung läuft
zudem ein Ermittlungsverfahren gegen den
22-Jährigen in Hessen haben sich CDU und
SPD auf einen Koalitionsvertrag geeinigt
Schwerpunkte des 184 seitenlangen
Dokuments sind Bildung und Sicherheit
die Parteigremien müssen dem Papier am
Wochenende nur noch zustimmen nach der
Wahl am 8 Oktober hatte sich die CDU von
Ministerpräsident rin überraschend gegen
ein neues Bündnis mit den Grünen und für
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der SPD
entschieden gestern also hat sich die
ampelregierung nach knapp vier Wochen
Verhandlungen zusammengerauft und sich
auf einen gekürzten Haushalt fürs
nächste Jahr geeinigt bei der Umsetzung
macht die Regierung jetzt Tempo morgen
schon steht die Erhöhung des Co zwei
Preises auf der Agenda des Bundestags
tanken und heizen dürfte damit jetzt
ziemlich schnell teurer werden
gleichzeitig hält die Kritik am
Sparpaket an Sozialverbände und
Gewerkschaften sehen eine soziale
Schieflage Politiker der Ampel dagegen
sind erleichtert Patrizia Wiedemeier aus
Berlin über den Tag
danach man glaubt es kaum aber es gibt
Tage in Berlin an denen Politiker auch
mal Herz und Gefühle zeigen heute morgen
war so eine Stunde im Parlament als sich
einer der dieses Land über viele Jahre
ja Jahrzehnte mitgeprägt hat
verabschiedete der grüne jürgend Trittin
ehemaliger Bundesumweltminister legt
nach 25 Jahren sein Bundestagsmandat
nieder und zum Schluss stellt er der
Ampel ein gutes Zeugnis aus es gibt in
Deutschland so viele
erwerbsarbeitsplätze wie nie zuvor in
der Geschichte wir haben 170 Gesetze
verabschiedet und jetzt gibt sogar ein
Haushalt
die el
handlungsfähiger als die Ampel manchm
selbst glaubt ja es gibt ihn seit
gestern einen Haushalt bzw Eckpunkte
eines Haushalts aber viele Details sind
nicht geklärt viele Fragen offen und
natürlich lässt die Kritik der
Opposition auch heute nicht lange auf
sich warten sie machen Deutschland er
das ist die Bilanz nach Z Jahren
ampelregierung in Deutschland sie
erhöhen den CO2 Preis kurzfristig
stärker als geplant sie erheben eine
Steuer und belasten Verbraucher und
Wirtschaft sie belasten die
Landwirtschaft massiv beim Thema
Agrardiesel kfzversicherung und machen
damit eine Politik gegen den ländlichen
Raum heizen Essen und tanken mache die
Ampel teurer so die Kritik doch klar ist
die Ampel braucht mehr Geld um z.B die
Bahn zu sanieren dazu sollen Aktien von
Telekom und Post verkauft werden und ca
12 Milliarden aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond genommen werden
ausreichend dürfte das nicht für die
Mammut Aufgabe beim Bürgergeld sollen
einige Bonusleistungen gestrichen werden
in der Summe bringt das jedoch nicht
viel das Bürgergeld selber soll und kann
nicht reduziert werden als Ausgleich für
die höhere CO2 Bepreisung fordern
Sozialverbände das lange versprochene
klimageld das jeder Bürger vom Staat als
Ausgleich erhalten soll um teure
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen abzufedern als
Sozialverband VdK fordern wir dass es
ein klimageld gibt das muss schnell
eingeführt werden damit der steigende
CO2 Preis gerade für ärmere Haushalte
ausgeglichen wird also tatsächlich
entlasten wir die Menschen im Jahre 2024
mit einem Riesenpaket unterschiedlicher
Maßnahmen wir haben im letzten Jahr
schon das Kindergeld auf 250 € erhöht
wir haben das 49 € Ticket eingführt wir
nehmen Milliarden in die Hand um bei der
Einkommenssteuer die arbeitenden
Menschen zu entlasten wir erhöhen das
Bürgergeld und durch eine Absenkung der
Stromsteuer unterstützen wir auch noch
einmal Unternehmen ob und wann es das
klimageld geben wird das bleibt aber
offen genauso wie viele weitere Fragen
zum Haushalt 2024 Details muss jetzt das
Finanzministerium vorlegen ab Januar
soll dann der Bundestag beraten erneute
Nachtsitzungen nicht
ausgeschlossen Deutschland ist mitunter
eine digitalwüste auch und besonders im
Gesundheitssystem dabei wäre gerade hier
der Austausch von Daten buchstäblich
lebenswichtig Beispiel Notaufnahme mit
einer digitalen Patientenakte wüsste der
Notarzt welche Vorerkrankungen der
eingelieferte hat und welche Medikamente
er schon nimmt und das ehrezept wird auf
der Versicherungskarte gespeichert und
in der Apotheke ausgelesen beides soll
jetzt kommen Luisa Huben
berichtet für sie hat die digitale
aufhohljagd bereits begonnen Ärztin
Silke Heinle hinterlegt seit di Wochen
die Rezepte für ihre Patienten auf deren
Versicherten Karte offiziell startet das
e-rezept erst im Januar ganze Welt ist
ja digital also von der denke ich es ist
uns Pflicht auch digital zu sein genauso
sieht das auch Bundesgesundheitsminister
Kar Lauterbach und will mehr die
elektronische Patientenakte
verpflichtend für alle gesetzlich
Versicherten einfach in einem Satz
gesagt eine bessere effizientere Medizin
die anderswo schon praktiziert wird die
wir kennen über die wir Jahre geredet
haben zwei entsprechenden Gesetzen
stimmte der Bundestag heute zu dem nach
soll ab
205 gchichte eines Versicherten von
überall einsehbar sein Diagnosen
Behandlungen Operationen so soll der
Austausch mit Fachärzten erleichtert
werden denn wer die Vorgeschichte kennt
kann besser behandeln versprechen sich
Ärzte am Anfang wird es eher ein Aufwand
sein wie immer ja bis die ganze Akte
angelegt
ist und aber ich denke wenn die Akten
dann angelegt sind und jeder Arzt dann
zugreifen kann dann glaube ich schon
dass es ein benefit ist vor allen Dingen
auch wenn es jetzt z.B um Impfungen geht
ja da verschl man die Patienten ganz
ganz gerne ihren Impfpass das e-rezept
kommt bei ihren Patienten gut an nur
manchmal hake es technisch wie wird es
wenn alle Daten digital gespeichert
werden wenn ich persönlich auch
nachgucken kann dann finde ich das
rundum gute Sache man muss nicht z be
meim Hausarzt immer Unterlage holen und
zum ander Arzt mitnehmen ich denke
gewiss Privatsphäre soll ja da schon
gegeben sein also wenn meine da alles
mögliche anstellt unterm Strich undich
davon weiß habe ich was dagege das
möchte ich eigentlich nicht denn die
E-Akte wird auch Infos zu Krankheiten
enthalten die für viele ein Tabu sind
wie Depressionen oder HIV alles wird
pseudonymisiert der Forschung zur
Verfügung gestellt werden wer da nicht
mitmachen will muss das Aktiv ablehnen
diese Widerspruchslösung kritisieren
Daten und patientenschützer aktiv
widersprechen heißt aber Schweigen als
Zustimmung auszulegen ebenu bedarf es
einer aktiven Zustimmung wenn die
pharmawissenschaft die Daten haben
ich gehe davon aus dass das weil es
nicht gegeben ist das
Bundesverfassungsgericht anmahen wird
die digitale Aufholjagd ob sie von den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern angenommen wird
hängt an der Umsetzung und daran ob es
gelingt Versicherte über die neuen
Möglichkeiten und ihre Rechte
aufzuklären und wir haben noch einmal
Nachrichten mit gundol Gause zuerst aus
der Wirtschaft in der EU soll künftig
ein eigenes lieferkettengesetz gelten
große Unternehmen S sollen dem nach vor
europäischen Gerichten zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden können wenn es in ihren
Produktions und Lieferketten zu Kinder
oder Zwangsarbeit kommt oder wenn
Umweltstandards missachtet werden
Wirtschaftsverbände befürchten mehr
Bürokratie und damit weitere
Wettbewerbsnachteile wie erwartet hält
die Europäische Zentralbank die
Leitzinsen vor der Jahreswende konstant
der für Sparer wichtige einlagenzins
bleibt bei 4% mit der Zinspause folgt
die EZB der US Zentralbank Valerie
Haller an der Börse wie genau begründet
die EZB aber ihre Entscheidung also
ezbchefin lagard sagt Zinssenkungen sein
überhaupt kein Thema gewesen die
europäischen Zentralbanker sind damit
tatsächlich wesentlich vorsichtiger als
die Fett die gestern mehrere
Zinssenkungen wenigstens in Aussicht
gestellt hat für die EZB jedoch ist der
Kampf gegen zu hohen Preisdruck noch
nicht ausgestanden kurz und
mittelfristig rechnet die Euro
europäische Notenbank zwar mit sinkender
Inflation aber auch mit einer
schwächeren Konjunktur dieses und
kommendes Jahr was die Notenbank vor
allem mit einer gedämpften
Auslandsnachfrage begründet vor allem
der angespannte Arbeitsmarkt bereitet
der Notenbank Sorge der Lohndruck sei
weiter hoch und wie reagierten die
Finanzmärkte auf die Entscheidung der
EZB
enttäuscht denn die hatten wohl gehofft
dass die EZB wenigstens perspektivisch
Lockerungen ankündigen würde die Börse
jedenfalls hat hatte darauf gewettet
Anleger daher ernüchtert der DAX gibt
nach dabei hatte er zwischenzeitlich
schon die 17 000 Punkte geknackt die
Börse geht davon aus dass die Zeit der
Zinserhöhungen nun vorbei ist die EZB
hat jedoch heute auch klar gemacht bis
die Zinsen wieder sinken wird es wohl
noch eine ganze Weile dauern vielen Dank
Valerie nach
Frankfurt die EU-Kommission hat im
Steuerstreit mit Amazon vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof eine endgültige
Niederlage erlitten die Kommission habe
nicht nachgewiesen dass das Land
Luxemburg dem Onlinehändler unzulässige
Beihilfen gewährt habe so der EGH es
ging um 250 Millionen Euro
gesellschaftssteuern die Luxemburg von
dem versandthändler nicht erhoben hatte
das sei keine begünstigende
steuervereinbarung bestätigte jetzt der
EGH zwei Ergebnisse im europäischen
Fußball mit deutscher Beteiligung in der
Europa League hat Bayer Leverkusen klar
gegen Molde FK aus Norwegen gewonnen
schon vor dem 5 Z1 Sieg hatte Leverkusen
das Achtelfinale sicher und in der
Conference League hat der schottische FC
aberdein am Abend Eintracht Frankfurt
2:0 besiegt Frankfurt muss damit als
Gruppenzweiter in die Zwischenrunde am
Sonntag treffen die Eintracht und
Leverkusen in der Bundesliga
aufeinander vor 40 Jahren waren sie
einer der größten Medienskandale in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik die
gefälschten hitlertagebücher heute
wurden 52 Kladden dem Bundesarchiv in
Koblenz übergeben dort sollen sie
digitalisiert und der Öffentlichkeit
zugänglich gemacht werden das Magazin
stern hatte die Fälschungen des Malers
konrad Kujau
1983 für eine Millionensumme gekauft und
in der Annahme veröffentlicht dass sie
echt waren wenig später flog der
Schwindel
auf das war's von uns wir empfehlen
Ihnen jetzt dringend den Talk bei der
echten Maybritt ilner unter dem Titel
Einigung in letzter Sekunde wie teuer
wird's fürs Land und um 0:30 Uhr meldet
sich nasan göcktem mir mit unserem heute
journal Update Ihnen einen wunderbaren
Abend und tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
wiedersehen
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter bevor das hoch die
wetterregie bei uns in Deutschland
übernimmt mischt sich noch mal eine
Front in das Wettergeschehen ein bringt
etwas Regen mit und zahlreiche Wolken
sehen es hier an den weißen Flächen also
es wird meist trüb sein und zum
Wochenende steigen die Temperaturen
etwas an es wird etwas milder schauen
wir in die kommende Nacht und da Schneid
es an den Alpen weiter ja Richtung Osten
hier in den ichen Mittelgebirgen auch
etwas Regen und den höheren langen
Schnee ansonsten in der zweiten
Nachthälfte von Nordwesten her neuer
Regen und das bei tiefsten Temperaturen
bis -3° hier nach Osten hin und 4° ganz
im Westen Richtung niederrehein und da
wo es hier frostig kalt ist müssen Sie
örtlich mit Glätte rechnen in den
höheren Lagen mit Schnee dann sowieso ja
und morgen dann hier und da etwas Regen
diese Front die sie gesehen haben zieht
allmählich nach Südosten hin an den
Alpen da lässt der Schneefall allmählich
nach das wird dann in den Abendstunden
sein und im Norden da ist etwas
Sonnenschein dabei mit höchsten
Temperaturen von 2° nach Osten hin und
9° im Westen die nächsten Tage es wird
trockener einzig am Samstag nach
Nordosten hin etwas Regen bei 2 bis 9°
hier und dort gibt's auch noch Nebel der
sich lange länger halten kann am Sonntag
wird's milder mit Temperaturen bis 11°
und damit einen schönen Abend